i've been sucking in
[Music]
we're gonna have a little america is
lizzo pregnant with chris evans baby
not exactly but captain america himself
has responded to lizzo's hilarious video
and it is good as hell i'm feeling good
as hell
it all started when the grammy winner
posted this tick tock
pretending to be pregnant with chris's
specifically captain america's
baby this is something that i've been
really trying to keep
personal and private just between me and
the father of my child but since we're
airing out all the rumors today
i've been sucking in
[Music]
we're gonna have a little america chris
took a dna test and 100
turns out he's that fake non-existing
baby's dad i just took a dna
test turns out i'm 100
a few days later lizzo shared what
appears to be a dm from the actor
who seemingly wrote quote hi just heard
about our little bundle of joy
my mother will be so happy lol it shook
me up
and it gets even better because chris
added
this hilarious request quote just
promise me
no gender reveal parties lol lizzo
captioned the tick tock quote
oh my god y'all he saw the baby bump we
did it
now y'all gotta name lil america what
y'all about to name my baby
i'm still sweating girl okay i'm excited
the detroit-born singer first decided to
shoot her shot with chris
back in april when she drunkenly slid
into his dms
the reason i'm upset about this one is
because
i know i'm not going to be able to marry
him and honestly it hurts me to the core
because damn papa he a rare breed no
comparing
like chris lizza posted that tick tock
video featuring an audio clip from
social media star tatiana mitchell and a
screenshot of the dm she sent the 40
year old actor
that's a gust of wind a female
basketball player
and a basketball emoji which fans
suspect loosely translates to lizzo
shooting her shot with the hollywood
heartthrob
now here's the t the caption don't drink
and dm
kids for legal purposes this is a joke
damn this is a big deal
pretty great right well it gets even
better because chris
he responded to the dm and subsequent
tick tock
and lizzo she shared his hilarious
response in
a second video the reason i'm upset
about
this one is because i know i'm not going
to be able to marry him
and honestly it hurts me to the court
because damn papa he a rare breed no
comparing
like chris yeah he responded to lizzo
writing
no shame in a drunk dm god knows i've
done worse on this app
lol the knives outstar might have been
referencing that one time he
accidentally leaked a nude photo of his
manhood to his insta story last
september
but back to lizzo back in 2019
she opened up to e.t about dating and
why she thinks it makes sense for
celebrities to date each other
it's like really hard to kind of siphon
through like
the bull find the real people but i mean
even famous people can be bullied
so i don't know i might just have to
marry myself again
another music video we just keep it
pushing like